en el sur de Delhi comienza un fin de
semana de festividades una boda una de
las 100.000 que se celebran cada año en
la capital India
muni sharma organiza la boda número 176
de su carrera
debe cuidar que cada detalle salga bien
recoge esa bolsa ten cuidado
Munich solo tuvo seis meses para
organizar esta boda y la seguridad del
lugar y de los invitados son su
prioridad
la gente se viste elegante y viene pero
esas personas no están invitadas agarran
comida agarran bebidas y se van no están
invitadas a la boda Mi trabajo es
asegurarme de que a mi cliente no lo
engañe nadie Eso es lo que hacemos
cámaras de vigilancia controles de
identidad de los invitados
guardias de seguridad
Munich toma todas las precauciones para
evitar cualquier contratiempo en sus
bodas su trabajo consiste en vigilar
esta zona entre 15 y 20 personas están
desplegadas y cada una vigila un área
hay alguien en el estacionamiento otra
persona en la puerta principal otra en
el vestíbulo si llega a ver un problema
que no pueden resolver dos personas mis
20 guardias de seguridad llegan allá y
en un segundo estamos listos para
intervenir las bodas son toda una
institución en India cada año se
celebran 10 millones de bodas y cada una
cuesta 30.000 euros en promedio tres
veces más que en Francia el número de
invitados suele ser desorbitado
en India una boda típica se hace delante
de 300 400 500 personas a veces
y algunas veces uno ni siquiera conoce a
los presentes porque tus padres tus
primos tus hermanos están tan contentos
que invitan a sus amigos a participar en
la celebración
largas listas de invitados a las que a
veces se auto invitan las personas mal
intencionadas
en ludiana en el estado de punjab
tilacrachad casó a su hijo el 29 de
enero ante 300 invitados pero a la hora
de cortar el pastel nada salió como
estaba planeado
aquí se ve que Detrás de mi mujer hay
dos personas con abrigos negros y crema
una de sus manos aparece agarra el bolso
y luego desaparece los ladrones se meten
en las bodas sin estar invitados se
camuflan entre la multitud y roban
regalos joyas y sobres llenos de dinero
30 o 40 segundos después nos dimos
cuenta de que el bolso había
desaparecido En ese momento hicimos un
escándalo para informar de la
desaparición del bolso nadie logró
encontrarlo esa noche fueron robados más
de ocho mil euros en efectivo
la policía de luidiana dice estar
investigando de cerca el caso el
inspector hardytzink está a cargo de la
investigación
a partir de octubre mes que marca el
inicio de la temporada de bodas en India
la policía ha estado analizando el modus
operandi de estas bandas
el fenómeno marginal hasta hace unos
años va en aumento los ladrones piensan
que habrá mucho dinero porque los
lugares donde se celebran las bodas
cobran entre 21.000 y 26.000 euros por
una noche
Así que saben que solo los ricos pueden
permitírselo
cuando ven los grandes autos y la gente
bien vestida piensan que será una gran
boda para actuar con discreción estas
bandas organizadas reclutan a niños
desfavorecidos como parte de sus equipos
a mil kilómetros en el estado de madiage
nos encontramos con vivech un nombre
falso para mantener su anonimato
actualmente tiene 14 años pero fue
reclutado por una banda de ladrones de
bodas cuando tenía tan solo 8 recibimos
entrenamiento Durante un mes después del
entrenamiento íbamos a las bodas a robar
había un muchacho mayor conmigo
como un amigo
me enseñaba a robar le dije que no iba a
ser capaz de hacerlo me dijo que no
tenía otra opción
le dije Okay hermano mayor
después de robar en seis bodas en punjab
mientras que sus Cómplices Fueron
arrestados por la policía vive huyó se
subió a un bus y regresó a su pueblo
debido a la falta de recursos su madre
accedió a que hiciera parte de una de
estas bandas durante tres meses vinieron
unas personas de la ciudad y Nos
llevaron le pidieron permiso a mi mamá
nuestras condiciones de vida eran malas
vivíamos en un barrio muy pobre No había
nada en casa por eso mi mamá me dijo que
me fuera porque eso nos ayudaría según
la policía algunas familias pueden
cobrar hasta seis mil euros por dejar
que sus hijos se unan a estas bandas
organizadas Durante un año y en la
inmensa mayoría de los casos estos robos
come tidos por menores no son procesados
judicialmente